let's talk about the media reaction
because shocker shocker a certain amount
of people are very very excited that
Tucker Carlson will not be on Fox News
tonight at 8 pm let's start with the
shrieking harpies at the view because
the news broke while they were on air
you know the view is on right now some
of you know this it's 11 A.M Eastern
that's when we do this show every day
that's the same time that the view is on
that means there are people mostly
Housewives eaten bon bons watch in the
view right now so we broke the news live
on air because we heard about it just as
it was breaking the view did as well our
reactions were I would say slightly
different word has just come down that
Fox news media and Tucker Carlson have
agreed to part ways
wave
[Applause]
you know we'll talk more about it
tomorrow because but we wanted to make
sure that we let you know what was going
on well can I can I ask the audience if
they'll help me do something
come on folks
[Applause]
thank you God Anna Navarro you know on
any given day you can honestly argue
that each one of them is the worst host
I know I've been more of a sunny host
and is like a psychopath deranged
lunatic racist but Anna like on any
given day you just never know poor Joy
wasn't even there for it yesterday must
have been getting her face rearranged
anywho uh the short-sightedness of these
women is really extraordinary because
they're they're applauding that a guy
that they don't like who has a different
Viewpoint than them even though the show
is called The View and Barbara Walters
originally set it up so that you'd hear
different views different points of view
from different people which is the
reverse of what the show has become uh
what they seem to not realize is that
Tucker is now right at this moment
bigger than he's ever been he's bigger
than he was two days ago and he was
pretty freaking huge two days ago he's
not going away right he's not
disappearing he's not going to not have
a show or not be involved in Media or
politics he's probably going to do
something much bigger if you strike me
down Darth I will become more powerful
than you can possibly imagine watch Star
Wars ladies do you not get it don't you
know how this thing works but okay you
can sing and applaud and get your
temporary little win but I assure you
ladies it will not last long
[Music]